you are the general
that is in charge of your life
in charge of the war the war of your
life some people talk about being the
CEO of your life I'm telling you you are
the general of your life because it's a
war it's a war going on
the battle that's going on in your life
to be
stronger and smarter and faster and
better
so that means as the general you're the
one
who decides what you do and how you're
going to do it
you come up with a strategy
it's on you
you create the tactics you as the
general in charge
you make the plan and you give the
orders to the Troops
that's what you do you direct them
because you are the general
but you gotta remember this
you
are also the troops
you are also the troops in your life you
have to both plan and you have to
execute
the the ideas that you come up with as
the general in charge
you're also
the troops that have to make those
plans happen
just like on the battlefield sure the
general comes up with a plan but it's
the soldiers that fight
for you as a person you have to do both
we often forget that
we often forget that we don't remember
that we
actually have to execute the plan
a lot of people forget that so I I have
a
thing that I do that I find makes it
easier to do this if I separate those
two elements in my head
right I separate those two elements in
my head how do I do that I I write down
things that need to happen
I write the orders to myself task lists
that's the general in me that's the
general of me doing the writing this is
what we're gonna do here's the plan
here's what we got to make happen and
then
the soldier receives the orders
the soldier sees them the soldier reads
them and then the soldier executes
the soldier doesn't ask questions
the soldier doesn't complain the soldier
doesn't hesitate the soldier executes
and you got to get that Soldier part of
your brain working
that's what the soldiers supposed to do
execute
so that's what you need to do you need
to separate and clearly understand those
two parts of your brain the general and
the soldiers and when the general and
the soldiers both do what they're
supposed to do that's a united front
and that's an Unstoppable Force that's
discipline up and down the chain of
command
and that
is how Wars are won
so be the general
be the soldiers and go win the war